empecemos por analizar la importancia de
Pelé pero en el ámbito deportivo
Hola muy buenas tardes Eh Rosa y a todos
quienes te siguen la verdad es que Pelé
Para mí fue uno de los mayores iconos
del fútbol mundial un jugador que superó
todas las marcas se superó marcó más de
mil goles incluso estuvo en diversas
partes del planeta Yo lo conocí en Chile
incluso cuando era pequeño ya era un
gran Astro en 1958 recordemos que venció
ese primer mundial y de ahí para
adelante se tornó para mí el mejor
jugador de o el mejor atleta de la
historia del fútbol mundial participó en
otros mundiales el 62 posteriormente
después estuvo en el mundial 66
Lamentablemente salió lesionado fue
campeón en 1970 Y a partir de ahí
comenzó a abandonar el fútbol pero no
dejaba de participar de torneos que eran
creados en el mundo entero Incluso en
África llegó a paralizar una guerra
entre dos países para ver a Pelé decir
algo mayor algo que ningún otro
deportista seguramente lo ha alcanzado
en el mundo en estos momentos él se
encuentra recluido ahí en el hospital
Albert Einstein y está en no todo bien
cuidado intensivo está en una sala común
incluso la hija Flavia recientemente
criticó un poco a la prensa por esta
preocupación mayor con respecto a la
salud de del Astro el exastro del fútbol
diciendo que lo acaban en forma
maliciosa esperando lógicamente un
desenlace que todavía no se ve venir
porque él está claro
defendiéndose de un cáncer al al colon
que se desparramó por otras otras eh
otros órganos pero que todavía está
lúcido y muy bien incluso respondió al
homenaje que le rendieron en Qatar no
Y usted Patricio destacaba algunos de
los hitos no de Pelé fuera de lo
estrictamente futbolístico no como
jugador a nivel social y político porque
destacó su figura
bueno él llegó a ser el ministro incluso
de deportes de uno de los gobiernos
después de la de la democratización de
Brasil y Tuvo una intensa participativa
muy activa en cuanto a los derechos
humanos y a los derechos de las de los
menores principalmente cuando él marcó
el milésimo gol ahí en el estadio
maracaná recordemos que él pidió que se
cuidase de los de los menores
abandonados y que estaban en las calles
de Brasil y bueno y él siempre tuvo la
participación muy activa en cuanto a a
defender el derecho de los de los
menores y de incluirlos de cierta forma
utilizando el fútbol para ello él fue el
que destacó a roviño a Diego y a una
serie de otros jugadores llevándolos al
Santo muy pequeños y brindando entre
todo tipo de apoyo y Esto fue
posteriormente utilizado para llevar a
Neymar y otros jugadores que se han
destacado en el en el concierto mundial
es decir una preocupación que él tiene
no solamente por la parte futbolística
como también por el bienestar de de la
gente menor en Brasil no y usted que lo
conoció en persona como es en la
distancia corta Pelé Bueno la verdad es
que soy muy accesible yo creo que una de
las grandes figuras en las cuales yo lo
entrevisté en cuatro oportunidades
Incluso en una de ellas y cuando
llevamos un diario que trabajaba la
tercera la hora tenía un programa para
llevar a menores eh de algunos equipos
de acá de Brasil y él colaboró
especialmente en eso incluso estuvo
presente en uno de estos torneos que se
llamaban camino a la fama decir una
persona muy accesible siempre estuvimos
eh contacto permanente y donde nos
encontramos Bueno nos encontrábamos
porque ahora últimamente lamentablemente
no está dando entrevistas pero siempre
trabajó de la mejor forma posible no